Sam how's morale morale is good I got
back from women a couple days ago now
I'm just enjoying a week off at home in
California how do our people treating
you differently after the wind no not
really I mean I think it was more of a
shock in London than it is here
tennis isn't the most popular sport in
America but I you know I guess people
watch Wimbledon a little bit so I you
know it's pretty much the same old for
me you beat Murray but the previous year
you beat Djokovic bigger victory for you
it definitely murid just because the
Murray mass was in a quarterfinal and
the Djokovic matches in a third round
they both felt similar but just because
this year winning in the quarter-final
makes my first semi-final you know the
stage is bigger so definitely definitely
this year any trash-talking that goes on
you know unfortunately not all the
tennis and you think every every guy the
top 100 everyone is pretty nice everyone
gets along in the locker room but
sometimes I think it would be good for
tennis if we had a little bit of
trash-talking like it we had in the 70s
but you know McEnroe and Connors and
board and these guys why don't you
started soon I mean I could if you give
you some ideas I guess I could I mean I
guess everyone so nice but there has to
be somebody that you just don't like
that they grunt or they take forever
like we know the gamesmanship that goes
on right yeah I mean there's there's a
couple you know every now I remember
Djokovic a few years ago had a period
where he would bounce the ball about 15
times before you would hit a serve it
might be you know guys have little
annoyances like that but it's not enough
test that you dislike the guy what's the
what's the name of the fan club that you
know are they known as the samurais yeah
I mean that started about 10 years ago
it was all my like best friends from
high school but now that I'm 29 they're
29 they've since moved on and got a real
job so they they don't have time to
travel around and cheer and take out
their shirts and put body paint on
anymore
what if you didn't wear white
like what happens at Wimbledon if you
you forget to wear or you it's an
off-white I think didn't somebody have
black underwear on guys had black
underwear on they had to change their
underwear yeah that was actually in the
Junior competition they may change their
underwear but if you have if you have
like a little too much color on any of
your shirts or hats or shoes there's
basically a Wimbledon wardrobe that they
have and they will bring you out one of
the Wimbledon shirts or the Wimbledon
hats and they will make you change how
nervous were you against Murray um you
know I was nervous right at the
beginning I went down 3-0 in about five
minutes
and then you know after that once I
finally held my servant got on the
scoreboard I relaxed a little bit but I
played on center court there about three
or four times before so was it my first
time out there but you always get some
nerves right away just because you don't
want to get embarrassed on such a big
stage like that how many times you faced
Roger Federer three times and and if
I've lost all three times and it hasn't
been as close to the scores indicated
you know as law 6-4 6-3 6-4 6-4 and he's
you know when he beats guys 6-4 6-3 it's
the easiest 6-4 6-3 you could have it
it's really not competitive a lot of the
times did you ever ask for like a racket
or a shirt or like soccer guys do this
and football players do do that in
tennis do you have any memorabilia I
don't
the only time guys will ask for rackets
and shirt is usually if it's for some
type of charity event that they're doing
you know I might have a charity event
that I want to donate a Roger Federer
sign racket and the guys are cool like
that but no one no one just kind of
switches racquets and shirts like they
do in soccer I don't have any really
tennis memorabilia at my house besides a
couple of my own trophies if you didn't
play tennis what would you be doing wow
that is a great question well I was
going to go to USC for tennis and I
right before school started ten years
ago I decided to go pro so I'm not sure
what I would have majored in but you
know but that's just that's just a guess
on
so I'm not sure what I would be doing
how big a Laker fan are you a huge Laker
fan I'm a been my team for 10 or 12
years I've been watching a summer league
watching Lonzo ball so hopefully they
can sneak into a playoff spot this year
really I mean I'm not optimistic but
that's what I want to thank did you meet
any of the fans there is some pretty
important people celebrities at
Wimbledon do you get to say hello
interact with any of these people yeah
you know they have like kind of a common
lounge area there and the only person I
met this year was actually draymond
Green who was there for two days
so I chatted with him for a little bit
but you know as you can see in the in
the Royal Box every day there's you know
princess princes princesses
Bradley Cooper you know you name it it's
just like the who's who of tennis or of
the celebrity world watching those
matches do you have to watch your
language it Wimbledon more than any
other tournament yes Wimbledon is the is
the is the tournament that will hand out
signs faster than anyone if you if one
bad word slips out of your mouth and
that could be on the smallest court the
furthest away from center court they
will hit you with a $2,500 fine so fast
have you been fined I got fined last
year yes this year I this year I was
good no fines but last year I did get a
fine would you drop an f-bomb yeah I did
it was huge you know that last year was
my first round match I was serving for
the match at 8 7 in the fifth set and I
lost serve and it just it had to come
out but I ended up winning the match so
usually if you win a match and you get
fined you're ok with it it's when you
lose a match and get fined where it
really hurts you Sam Querrey the u.s.
pro tennis player a big win over Andy
Murray what's your ranking now in the
world the new rankings came out today
and I'm number 23 all right is that the
highest you know I've been as high as 17
before but I'm in a good spot right now
at 23 because the way the tennis
rankings work I don't have any points to
defend the rest of the year so you know
essentially at my rank you can only go
up from for the next six
how would you describe the state of
men's tennis US men's tennis you know
it's not that I mean we don't have the
Grand Slam champions like we had with
Agassi Sampras Chang Courier but we've
got four guys in the top thirty right
now John is there Jack Sox feed Johnson
micelles and then we've gotten about
five or six guys that are like 19 or 20
years old that are on the top hundred so
we're really deep we just don't have
that grand slam champion that we had you
know in the 90s explain this reality
show Millionaire Matchmaker in 2015
because it doesn't sound like it went
well it did it but it was fun there's a
it's pretty much the cheesiest dating
show you could be on and it's on the
Bravo network and I did it yeah almost
two and a half three years ago and yeah
you know I didn't find love on it
although I have a great great girlfriend
now we didn't meet on that show but if
it was something that was that was fun
and my buddies definitely made fun of me
for it okay wait how do you get to the
point where you're going to be on
Millionaire Matchmaker and put yourself
out there for everybody to see my agent
came to me and said hey there's this
show if you if you want to be on it and
I kind of debated it for a while and
then kind of said what the hell and went
on it and you know as corny and as
cheesy as it was it was actually a lot
of fun and I had a great time doing it
if I said you could be any tennis player
on tour aside from yourself you could
have their life whose life do you want
it's got to be Federer I mean the guy
seems beloved by everyone the best of
all time he's when I say all the guys
are nice in the locker room but he's the
nicest guy too
I mean he's just it's hard to the other
players I you know just watch him on the
TV all day his matches on everyone's in
the watch locker room watching him
they're just you're just an awesome at
all times
do you issues a little bit of a jerk oh
yeah I mean he certainly has a like an
arrogance and a cockiness about it but
it's been a good one I mean it's in a
way of he knows he's the best if one of
my guys face you like
come out to California again we come out
we usually stay in Santa Monica is that
where you live that's B I live in Santa
Monica do you go to big Dean's at all
down at the beach do you go down there
and have beers I've been there a few
times my dad that's like my dad's
favorite spot you down there all the
time and I've been there a couple times
all right that's usually where we go
maybe next time we're there we'll get
your dad to come down and we'll have
some beers with him but if I had you
served to one of my guys would they be
able to is there any chance that they'd
be able to return serve assuming they
don't play tennis I would say no I mean
I could probably hit a hundred serves at
them they might get one in play okay but
for a novice person to try to return a
professional service very difficult
could you try to specifically hit them
in like a nut shot oh yeah that's really
my language much good now sometimes if
I'm if I'm on the course with some
buddies or my casual assess messing
around I'll always try to hit the serve
as hard as I can just right at their
chest and hope it hits them have you
ever tried to hit the ball boy the guy
who's standing there detention have you
ever tried to smoke one of those mole
boys I've never tried to smoke a ball
boy but there might be like a lines
umpire in the fact that maybe has had a
tough call again you and you're kind of
you might miss the serve on purpose and
try to hit that guy okay
it's understandable hey congrats
obviously it was a great performance
there and hopefully bigger and better
things but when we come to Santa Monica
again if you can't make it out then
we're getting the old man down there and
having some beers at the big deans that
sounds good thank you Sam thanks so much
guys night got a new tennis player to
root for Sam Querrey I like it
that's good performance here the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience